herzlich willkommen zum Wohnungsprojekt
dem Projekt in dem ich eine Wohnung
kaufe alles rausreißen sie renoviere und
nach meinen und euren Träumen Umbau der
Mann mit dem geknitterten T-Shirt der
Welt ist wieder da denn ich befinde mich
gerade in Asien Blogs gibt's auf dem
zweitkanal linkes in der
Videobeschreibung in diesem Video kann
man wir uns endlich ums Badezimmer das
parallel zu den ganzen anderen
Umbauarbeiten auch gemacht wurde
deswegen springen wir etwas in der Zeit
zurück denn der Prozess vom Bad hat hat
ewig gedauert und ich habe mir das ganz
besonderes einfallen lassen wenn euch
die gesamte Wohnung Serie gefällt dann
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
und das Video zu liken und jetzt viel
Spaß mit dem Video vielleicht erinnert
ihr euch noch die Wohnung ist von 1973
also ziemlich genau 50 Jahre alt und so
sah das Bad eben auch aus altes
Waschbecken alte Toilette alte Fliesen
und vor allem eine Sitzwanne absolut
gruselig und natürlich nicht das was wir
uns vorstellen in diesem Wohnungsprojekt
wir wollen alles auf obersten Standard
und so eben auch das Bad ihr wisst ja
wir haben schon alles rausgerissen ich
habe mit dem Schlag kann man schon alle
Fliesen entfernt und mühselig die
Sitzwanne raus transportiert und dann
mit dem SRK Betrieb meines Vertrauens
neue Leitungen verlegt denn die Alten
waren tschüss und super ekelhaft was wir
wollen ist mehr Platz ein besseres
Raumgefühl und möglichst eine bodentiefe
Dusche fast gar nicht so einfach ist
wenn es nicht von vornherein so geplant
ist und wir müssen eben mit dem arbeiten
was wir haben die Planung dieser Wohnung
kam aus der Community über 300
Vorschläge gewonnen hat weiter mit die
von Markus unheimlich geiler Plan so
haben wir ja den Raum an sich schon
umgebaut und fürs Bad gab es eine grobe
Aufteilung aber keinen gestalterischen
Vorschlag also mussten wir uns darum
kümmern über ein bisschen Recherche und
Info auf Pinterest habe ich drei
Optionen erarbeitet die mir gut gefallen
die grundsätzlich im Bad gut passen
würden und die einfach nice werden
Option 1 wäre sowas wie eine Hommage ans
alte Badezimmer aber neu interpretiert
grüne Fliesen Goldtöne bei den Armaturen
und nun ja so eine neue Interpretation
einfach von einem 70er Jahren war Option
zwei viele dunkle und holzige Töne super
modern und trotzdem sehr schick hat mir
auch sehr gut gefallen option 3 super
clean keine Fliesen deutlich heller und
ein bisschen weniger farbenfroh aber
dafür wirklich komplett liegen ich habe
am Anfang gesagt wir brauchen möglichst
viel Platz und möglichst gutes Raum
Option 2 ist super cool aber ziemlich
dunkel weswegen die eigentlich relativ
schnell rausgefallen ist weil die den
Raum noch mal ein bisschen enger machen
würde und man vielleicht so ein bisschen
bedrückendes Gefühl hätte also Option
zwei schon mal raus Option 1 mega cool
ich habe aber etwas Bedenken gehabt ob
die goldenen Armaturen nicht so ein
bisschen zu flashig sind für die sonst
sehr clean eingerichtete Wohnung also
wir haben ja nur Eichen Töne und
ansonsten komplett weiß mit goldenen
Armaturen und Grünen Fliesen weiß ich
nicht ob das so 100% gepasst hätte und
um ehrlich zu sein hat mir option 3 die
komplett kleine Variante auch einfach am
besten gefallen nicht nur ist diese
Option am praktikabelsten weil super
hell und schlicht sondern irgendwie auch
mega modern und zeitlos also mit Abstand
war dass das rundeste Konzept was ich
mir für dieses kleine Wartezeit
vorstellen kann noch ein bisschen
Recherche ist mir aber aufgefallen dass
ich wahrscheinlich selber die Finger
davon lassen sollte im Bad darf wirklich
nicht schief gehen wenn auch nur ein
Tropfen am Tag irgendwo durchsickert
sind das 365 Tropfen im Jahr und das Bad
ist nass und dieses komplette Projekt
geht den Bach herunter weil wir
langfristig wieder Wände aufmachen
müssen irgendwas trocknen müssen also
keine Faxen ich habe mich auf die Suche
gemacht und Profis gefunden
[Musik]
und während ihr im Hintergrund jetzt
gearbeitet wird habe ich den Chef und
Gründer von einwandfrei Marcel linke
neben mir aber was macht ihr eigentlich
was macht einwandfrei ja also wie wir ja
hier zeigen dürfen bauen mit ihr gerade
deinen Fußbad und genau darauf haben wir
uns jetzt seit sieben Jahren fokussiert
und spezialisiert die haben einfach mal
die Möglichkeit mit dir wirklich zu
zeigen wie viele Arbeitsschritte
eigentlich dazu gehören um am Ende ein
schickes Bad zu bekommen wohlfühl Bad
und da gibt's noch eine Menge mehr zu
entdecken und genau damit geht's auf dem
einwandfrei Kanal weiter den über den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
findet aber da findet ihr nicht nur
coole Info für eure Bäder oder Böden
sondern auch potentiell eure neuen
traumjobieren können denn ihr habt eine
Menge Stellen zu besetzen und schaut da
gerne vorbei da gibt's mehr Infos und
noch viel mehr Kram zu entdecken
[Musik]
während sich im Badezimmer schon fleißig
um Bodendecke und Wände gekümmert wurden
habe ich mich noch mal auf den Weg
gemacht um schlussendlich wirklich die
richtige Ausstattung auszuwählen welche
Toilette was für ein Spülkasten was für
eine Dusche was für Armaturen und so
weiter und das Bad eben noch mal von
Experten kamen zu lassen damit ich da
wirklich keinen Fehler mache heute ist
ein ganz besonderer Tag wir wählen
nämlich genau hier all das aus was wir
fürs Bad brauchen also Toilette
Armaturen Waschbecken alles was wir
brauchen bin mir in einer Ausstellung wo
ich hoffentlich all das finde was ich
suche da gehen wir rein und gucken was
wir in unserem Bad verbauen auf einer
riesigen Ausstellungsfläche findet man
hier alles am Bad Ausstattung was man
braucht also Keramik Waschbecken
Toiletten und so weiter unzählige
Armaturen und vor allem aber super viele
Berufe ist in dem Beispiel wäre da in
verschiedensten Stilen ausgestellt
werden solltet ihr also noch keine
Ahnung haben oder noch nicht 100 %
wissen wie Euer nächstes Bad aussehen
soll dann werdet ihr hier auf jeden Fall
für mich könnt euch das alles anschauen
und vor allem aber anpacken und einfach
mal sehen fühlen und ja im Raum stehen
und sich überlegen ob das zu einem passt
so ein Duschkopf ist ein absolutes Must
Have für mich in der Wohnung irgendwas
von oben dazu noch eine Brause und auch
das hier wieder in schwarz also es
gefällt mir schon wirklich am besten
also die Ausstellung ist wirklich
riesengroß hier sind so verschiedene
Kohlen aufgebaut damit man nicht einfach
20 Waschbecken in einer Reihe hat und
sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann wie
das am Ende wirklich in dem Bad wirkt
sowas hier gefällt mir eigentlich schon
ziemlich gut schwarz Armaturen super
schlicht irgendwas in diese Richtung
eigentlich möchte ich relativ wenig
Schnick Schnack ich habe mich ja extra
für fugenloses Bad entschieden um es
möglichst clean zu halten und ich glaube
da könnten so schwarze Armaturen schon
richtig gut kommen ein weiteres Problem
ich habe zu wenig Platz um den
Unterputzspülkasten einzubauen das Bad
ist einfach super klein das birgt einige
Schwierigkeiten deswegen gehe ich jetzt
gleich in eine professionelle Beratung
und schauen wir mal an was die Profis
dazu sagen wie sie mein Bad gestalten
wird wie gestalten wir das dass wir
überall genug Bewegungsspielraum haben
wie groß nehmen wir das Waschbecken
damit groß genug ist damit wir uns
entspannt die Hände waschen können aber
klein genug bin ich unnötig Platz
wegnehmen ich habe 3D Renderings
bekommen und konnte mir das dann alles
auch noch mal zu Hause durch den Kopf
gehen lassen und so weiter diese ganzen
Details die super wichtig sind über die
Links in der Videobeschreibung findet
ihr alles was ihr braucht um euer neues
Bad euer neues Traumbad mit Profis in
Angriff zu nehmen und da wirklich nichts
falsch zu machen es lohnt sich klick da
drauf check das aus und macht einen
Termin im Endeffekt also alles bestellt
und zurück in die Wohnung unglaublich
wie aufwendig das fugenlose Spachteln
des Bades ist super viele Schichten
verschiedene Schichten für Feuchträume
für Trockenräume und so weiter die
unterschiedlich lang Aushärten müssen
ich glaube 17 Arbeitstage hat der
Prozess im Endeffekt gedauert weil eben
Schicht für Schicht für Schicht
aufgetragen werden muss das hätte ich
niemals selber hinbekommen und genau
deswegen bin ich unheimlich happy mit
der Firma zusammen zu arbeiten mit den
absoluten Profis die das nach bestem
Wissen und Gewissen und auf höchstem
Standard machen Jungs und Mädels bei
einem Mann frei suchen immer neue Leute
für ihr Team wenn ihr schon immer mal
aus Köln Arbeiten wolltet aus Köln leben
wollte planen nach Köln zu ziehen eher
Köln kommt dann schaut euch das mal an
da werdet ihr mit Sicherheit für mich
während ich also wie bei den anderen
Videos auch schon für Seven
S in Panama war wurde das Bad weiter
gebaut und nicht nur weil ich nicht im
Land sondern ich hätte wahrscheinlich eh
nicht helfen können alle Sachen sind
angekommen die ganze Keramik ein neuer
schwarzmatter Heizkörper der super
sleeak aussieht ein neuer Spiegelschrank
super moderne schwarzmatte Armaturen
also wirklich
picobello vom allerfeinsten unglaublich
was für ein Aufwand für diese kleine
piss-wohnung es ist wirklich in Worte zu
passen ich habe da einfach komplett
übertrieben
das bringt eigentlich auf den Punkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben es im Endeffekt tatsächlich
hinbekommen
[Musik]
wir haben es im Endeffekt wir haben es
im Endeffekt tatsächlich hinbekommen
eine bodentiefe Dusche einzubauen dafür
einen extra schmalen extra flachen
Ablauf in die Dusche eingebaut wir haben
eine Regendusche einbauen können dafür
einen extra größeren Durchlauferhitzer
eingebaut wir haben den Monolithen
eingebaut das ist ein super flacher
Spülkasten fürs WC aber nicht nur
irgendein Monolithen sondern Monolith +
mit großabzug weil wir ja kein Fenster
haben mit Bewegungssensor für Licht
damit man nachts wenn man auf die
Toilette geht nicht das Grille Licht von
der Decke anmachen muss sondern so ein
leichtes dezentes LED angeht also wir
haben eine LED-Beleuchtung für unsere
Toilette wir haben komplett übertrieben
alles nur vom allerfeinsten und das
ganze sieht dann doch vielleicht ein
bisschen besser aus als die sitzbade ich
glaube tatsächlich dass das Badezimmer
meinen absolut mit der Einbaulösung mein
absolutes Highlight an der gesamten
Wohnung ist weil das so eine krasse
Veränderung durchgemacht hat weil die
ganzen Sachen die wir ausgewählt haben
komplett also wirklich sind alles zehn
von zehn der Monolith ist geil die
Duschabtrennung ist geil die Regendusche
ist geil der Heizkörper ist geil
insgesamt lässt sich hier gar nicht
beschreiben wie viel Köpfchen in jeden
einzelnen Zentimeter rein geflossen ist
und mit Sicherheit gibt es jetzt schon
wieder Sachen die ich gerne noch anders
gemacht hätte die ich beim nächsten Mal
anders machen würde aber all in all ist
die Wohnung auf so kleine Raum einfach
super gut durchdacht komplett
overpowered umgebaut und ich bin mega
happy wäre natürlich sehr gerne deutlich
mehr beim Badumbau dabei gewesen ich
kann mich aber nicht teilen war in
Panama und deswegen musste das ohne mich
passieren ich hoffe euch hat das Video
trotzdem gefallen ich hoffe euch gefällt
das Bad ich hoffe euch gefällt das Video
ich hoffe euch gefällt mein Youtube
Kanal lass mir gerne ein Like da
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
um die roomto nächste Woche nicht zu
verpassen wo ich noch mal auf jedes
Detail eingehen wo wir uns einen richtig
schönes Video zusammengebastelt haben
macht's gut bis zum nächsten mal vielen
Dank an Peach und an einwandfrei fürs
Badezimmer ich küss eure Herzen macht's
gut tschüss